hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the preliminaries it's day three
now of the gold money asian rapid and
it's already richer versus levon arun
already starting off with a with an
incredible game
uh so let's just check it out and then
we'll see what else
what else can happen on this great day
so uh furuja with
the white pieces opens with e4 and lavon
who is leading the tournament after
yesterday uh replies with
e5 we have knight to c3 knight to f6
and now bishop to c4 and now uh
yesterday we said that here you can you
know just continue development but
sometimes the black
even plays knight captures on e4 and
it's a very tricky variation
and this is exactly what levon goes for
he plays knight captures on e4
and you don't want to accept this piece
if you accept this piece then
black can strike with d5 and then he has
a double attack and then black achieved
what he wanted
but here we have queen the h5 uh also
known as the
old this entire you know uh
funny business uh opening is is called
the
frankenstein dracula variation if
anyone's interested
so here queen to h5 now threatening
checkmate
and knight the d6 i think we showed this
exact line yesterday
all right so now defending uh checkmate
they're now attacking the bishop so
bishop goes back to b3
bishop to e7 and now queen captures an
e5 and now
you can see that white doesn't really
have any issues here and black has a
weirdly placed knight on d6 um
but levon uh seems to have prepared
something exactly
for for this uh occasion so here we have
castles and
now d4 and while you want to play rook
to e8 it
does make sense since the queen and king
are both on the e file
after queen to h5 you don't really have
any good discoveries wherever you go
doesn't really matter bishop f6 check
we're just going to block this is nicely
protected we're going to castle
everything is working nicely for us
uh so here uh after this uh d4 move we
have knight to c6
attacking uh alireza's queen queen back
to f4 and now
knight to a5 going after this very
strong light square bishop
so alireza wastes a few tempe to save it
we have bishop to d5
knight to e8 by lavon uh and bishop to
f3 now so really really re-maneuvering
this bishop
and now there is a game from 2014 tata
still masters uh that ended in a draw
between anishigiri and fabiano karwana
fabi had the white pieces here
uh and anish continued with knight back
to c6 but here levon goes bishop to b4
and it is already as a move tender we
have a completely new game so let's see
uh what alireza can do for this well uh
seemingly uh prepared line as uh well
you don't play this line if you if if
you didn't come ready
uh here you could just continue
developing for example knight to the e2
but
then you allow black to play d5 and
black is very happy
so here i think valeria wanted to
prevent this and he played d5 himself
but now
levon eliminates this knight he uh
doubles up the pawns here
on the c file we have captures captures
and the b6 now
so uh what's the idea well the knight
here on a5 although
somewhat weirdly placed the guards the
c4 square so you're not going to be able
to just push c4 at any point okay now
the queen is guarding it but the queen
will not remain there forever
and you can uh pile up on this pawn for
example with the bishop with the knight
and uh
levon has some ideas here and although
uh this is now
uh this is now here just advancing the
pawn doesn't really do anything we're
just gonna play bishop to a6
and this is a dream scenario for for
black there are you know
if you've studied the games of old
masters old masters would often
sacrifice this rook
uh to keep the white king in the center
of the board so here if you capture for
example captures uh the queen will
capture and now this is uh
this is attacked the bishop will be
preventing the king from castling the
the knight will move the rook is coming
into the game it's just not going to be
possible to defend this with white
so instead after b6 just knights the e2
alireza wants to castle his king to
safety now comes
bishop to a6 uh we have castles and
now queen to f6 levon says okay my pawn
structure is much better
uh let's trade queens and let's uh just
continue this game
uh but alireza says nope not interested
i'm going to play queen to a4 and now
i'm attacking this pawn
as well as now i might be preparing this
as now my king is uh safely tucked away
so
this could be this could become possible
so levon plays knight to d6 he prevents
this pawn from being pushed any further
activates the knight and
gives up the d7 pawn and alireza not
want to back down from a challenge
except
the pawn we have queen captures on d7
now comes
rook 8 to e8 it's not much but a
developed rook for the price of one pawn
it's it's not bad
and alireza now needs to be very careful
as
danger lurks everywhere and he plays
bishop to e3 now there's a double attack
on the knight so you need to figure out
how to defend
this knight uh you can't really move it
because then uh bishop captures an f1
you lose the exchange
so you might add another defender here
with a move like queen to g4
or you can do what alireza played he
played bishop to e3
now the rook no longer attacks the
knight but now there's a problem there's
a move so strong for lavon
uh that it simply uh completely shatters
alireza's position uh so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this incredible move uh while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
well grabbing your least active piece
and doing something with it okay the
least active piece could be this rook
but this rook cannot move so we have to
bring this knight
so congratulations to everyone who
decided to play knight eight to c4 it's
such a weird move to play when you're
looking for
a move that you know gives you
considerable advantage uh but here it
just makes sense now there's a double
attack on this bishop so
what can you do here well not much again
uh bishop to d4
is what was played in the game and it
makes sense it attacks the queen
but now comes the real idea knight to e5
uh which was the idea all along even if
you didn't play bishop to d4 but now
at least after knight to e5 attacking
the queen and the bishop here on f3
now you can eliminate this knight but
even this doesn't help you because if
you play bishop captures the rook
captures and e5 again
there's a double attack here on the
knight and once you play
uh something uh for example rook after
e1 we're just going to play rook after
e8
uh and you will lose now we're just
gonna pick up the piece or if you move
it we're just gonna win the game
uh right away and if you don't uh defend
with the rook if you move the knight to
then you have to give up the exchange
and that's uh enough for for black to
have a winning advantage uh however
after knight the e5 alireza said all
right i'm going to go back with the
queen and play queen to h3
and now uh levon just eliminates uh the
defender of the knight on e2 he plays
knight characters on f3 with
check g captures and now queen to g5
check as the queen is hanging here
so queen to g5 check king to h1 and now
uh queen captures on d5 the problem is
uh you don't have time to go
uh p is grabbing because if you play
something like bishop captures on e2
then rook to g1 and then it's uh black
who who might be in trouble
because that that's really going to hurt
so
instead what you could do after king to
h1 you might consider a move like
f6 yes this is one of those positions
where just playing f6 is the best move
uh but levon captured on d5 and now he
allowed alireza
for a very very uh sneaky idea rook the
g1
and now levon played f6 he said all
right i didn't play it uh
on that move i'm playing it now uh so
there's nothing you can do here
however there is something alireza can
do uh
we'll see if he did it or not but feel
free to pause the video here
and try to find it the only move for
white uh that
uh well uh might even win the game
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on
uh you know utilizing both rooks
and the just you know going through
black's defenses and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook captain g7 and now the point is uh
after king captures we're gonna bring
the other rook to g1
with check and now you can't go to f7 if
you go to f7 then it's just
check king will move to e6 and knight to
f4 is checkmate so
there's that so the king has to go to h8
and the defended the h7 pawn like this
king the h8
but now we bring the knight to f4 with
an attack on the queen and also just
threatening knight to g6 check because
this pawn is pinned
so here queen to f7 would be played now
knight the g6 check
king the g8 and now the very important
knight the e5
check attacking the queen and the the
the king is still in check
so better just to block with the queen
so at least we grab a rook so queen to
g7
we're going to pick up the queen with
check king captures and now you get this
position where white is better but
i whether it will be enough for a win
it's it's hard to say but probably
in a rapid game where you can just you
know push for or advantage if you have
sufficient time
for example queen g3 check king h8 and
now we can even play
queen to f4 to really put um
some problems uh you know towards black
because we're attacking this pawn with
the queen we can play some like knight
here attack the rook get again a triple
attack on the f6
pawn and of course uh if the if this is
accepted then just bishop captures an e5
and we win the game
uh you can either give up the rook or
you can start running away with the king
but it doesn't help just
check king of seven we're going to
deliver check king g8 and queen g7
checkmate
so uh such ideas are in the position
after f6 but alireza trusted levon
he played knight to f4 first probably
thinking it's pretty much the same idea
i can always
play rook captures on g7 on the next
move but now queen to
f5 and now it's uh now it's a little bit
different because now if you capture
king captures and rook to g1 check king
the f7 is
possible uh queen is now guarding this
uh
h7 h7 pawn so there's no queen captures
on h7
so instead after queen to f5 we have
queen to h6
now just threatening queen captures and
g7 checkmate so rook to f7
level on defense and now rook to g3
preparing to double up here on the g
file uh levon grabs uh the pawn on c2 we
have queen captures on c2
uh and now comes knight the h5 now with
a triple attack here on the g7 pawn but
levon also has a knight he plays knight
to f5 now attacks the rook and
the queen and the guards the g7 square
so here alvarez has to go for it
otherwise
the game is over knight captures on f6
with check
uh we have rook captures and now rook
captures and g7 with
check we have knight captures and g7 and
queen captures on f6 now threatening
checkmate here
uh but levon uh also has
something to say about this he plays
queen to g6 now
defense against checkmate and alireza
says all right let's just play
rook to g1 at least after captures
capture so i'm still going to be able to
capture on g7
and we play this game however there is
now one move that ali reza missed so
feel free to pause the video for the
third time
and win this game for lavon while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on always
always looking for a great ways to
sacrifice your queen
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's of course rook captures and g1
with check uh and it was in this
position uh after uh levon played this
that alireza faruja resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
uh or maybe he didn't or maybe just
thought he resigned here
i will check however let me just check
real quickly yes it was in this position
that he
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh the problem is
the only movie is king captures
on g1 and now there's this rook the e1
check
king to g2 and now the bishop comes
bishop to f1 check and now there's a
problem if you go king g1 or king to h1
you're just getting checked mated with
bishop to h3
uh the king has nowhere to go and if you
go up the board well that's the whole
point then knights the h5 check wins the
queen back and
then black is just up a full rook you're
gonna play anything just knight captures
bishop captures
we're up a whole rook we're winning
winning this game easily
so really an outstanding game levon
really came
nicely prepared with that sneaky line
with knight captures on e4 right in the
opening which is not something
you would usually play against uh uh
well against a
super grand master but here he makes it
work
and you know every the entire game was
played perfectly that he gave alireza
that one chance he played f6 one moved
too slow
but alireza missed it and that was all
it took
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it levon's still in the lead after this
um
uh remarkable win uh i think ding also
won his game so i think
it's a it's a shared lead but you know
the the day is still young
we'll see what happens so once again
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank andre sandu david kimura nigel
holloway
happy birthday gavin and leander uh
[ __ ] for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day